it's great to welcome to the program
today Neil Irwin who's the author of how
to win in a winner-take-all world a new
book about navigating a successful
career in the modern economy he's also a
senior economic correspondent at the New
York Times Neil so great to have you on
today thanks for having me David so I
think that in the last six to twelve
months of the political cycle
increasingly discussions about work are
related to number one a coming
technological unemployment and what jobs
that will destroy versus what jobs it
will create questions of minimum wage
some broader questions about the
relationships of human to work humans to
work but let's step back from that a
little bit I mean if we look at the last
50 years and the idea of working for a
company for an entire career pensions
which are increasingly not available to
more and more workers how is the
landscape kind of changed about the
relationship of people to to their jobs
in the United States yeah I think what
it means to have a job has really
shifted underneath our feet over the
last last 30 40 years as you say and I
think the important thing is to is to
understand those changes and understand
what that implies for for how you
navigate your own career so what I did
with this book is I tried to go around
to these big companies that are dominant
in the modern economy and asked ok what
does it take to succeed and thrive in
this organization and then what does it
take to have a long and durable career
we can talk more about some of the some
of the lessons I learned but I think
you're fundamentally right I think when
in a world where you know employers are
not going to be loyal to you necessarily
you can't count on that job you have
being the same job 5 or 10 years from
now I think the important thing is
having a kind of reciprocity and having
a sense of honesty that you know career
is a series of changes a series of steps
it's more like a series of hookups than
it is like a long time a long term
marriage and I think that's the most
important lesson about how this economic
change what that implies for the rest of
us so there are some who will hear that
sort of general overview and say well
that there's nothing natural or
necessary about that change in the sense
that if only there was X type of
regulation that may maybe that that
change may have been restricted for
example there are others who will say
that those changes are more about life
expectancy and the fact that people
may just by their nature live in more
places and work different jobs and
that's a good thing and and companies
are just sort of reacting to those
desires and there's really not a problem
per se to be fixed here how much of this
do you think is regulation related how
much is socio-cultural change in the
states how much is something else
altogether I think there's two pieces of
it as you suggest and and part of this
is choices we've made as in through the
political system and as a society that
don't have to be made this way right
you know unions have become less
powerful there's been kind of shift you
know the entire gig economy rests on the
legal interpretation of independent
contractor law and and you know
companies are able to kind of outsource
things because the law allows them to
and you know those are choices that
could be made in Washington that would
tilt the other direction and that's kind
of what this next presidential election
is going to be all about is what what
should those what should those settings
look like but I think I argue and I
really strongly believe that part of
this is driven by technological
fundamentals and and things that aren't
really going to change no matter what
happens in the political system so
things around rapidly changing business
models for example I work in the
newspaper business right you know there
is nothing that could have that
government could have done that would
result in the print newspaper not
monopoly is still existing the way they
did 20 years ago and I started my career
it's digital media and and that's has an
entirely different way of working and
and requires different types of skills
than the old more linear kind of print
model did you know in every industry you
see change like that retail finance you
know certainly any element of technology
and I think we'd be foolish if we don't
acknowledge that those changes are
driven by really powerful fundamental
forces and learn how to adapt and
respond accordingly yeah I mean so
thinking about those forces in in
preparation for our interview I read
some opinion pieces which suggested that
actually there's certainly going to be
significantly different outcomes in
one's career based on the industry in
which they work I mean there are
industries that go under or are
significantly reduced in size and that
in those cases there may be factors
bigger than one's own sort of education
and and kind of actions and personality
but that in many cases it's not so much
about particular ski
but it's more about personality and I
guess you would call it social skills
understanding such basic concepts as
it's really important for your boss to
like you because if your boss doesn't
like you in corporate culture it's going
to be extraordinarily difficult to get
ahead no matter how good you are at what
you're doing and sort of these other
social dynamics and I find that really
interesting but I also find it dangerous
because there are people who take that
approach who like to use it to defend
drastically unequal economic outcomes so
while I find it interesting and probably
partially accurate I don't want to go
overboard in that direction I'm curious
what your thought would be on the skills
education personality factors in terms
of dictating or predicting success yeah
so um so have a concept I kind of
develop in this book of something called
a glue person and what we see in these
the big technologically sophisticated
companies that are the superstar firms
that are the real winners in this
winner-take-all economy they they have
team-based work and pull together people
on teams with very different technical
skills so you know you might have a
software engineer working with you know
a finance person working with a you know
user interface person working with a
strategy person and you need all those
skills to come together to create a
great product and so the people who are
really effective are those who can make
a team more than the sum of its parts
who can help that team stick together
that's why I call them a glue person and
I think cultivating your ability to be
that person is is really important and
to the personality piece it doesn't come
naturally to everybody it is something
we a lot of stuff to work on but
learning how to communicate and
collaborate with people who have a
different kind of technical background
than yourself is just a really really
important thing and I think is is really
a crucial thing to being the kind of
worker who's really valuable and needed
in these types of organizations that
that are really the future and the
present of the economy when it comes to
technological automation and there has
been so much written about the degree to
which this is going to be a problem and
specifically in which industries or
types of industries is this going to be
a problem how much is it being discussed
now within the corporations you
interviewed people and talked to you for
your book yeah I think it's
it's the predominant shift that's going
on and I think the real question is you
know is automation AI machine learning
all these things all these technologies
that are potentially enabling lots of
different jobs to go away I think for
most of us the thing to do is ask ok how
can I be the driver of that change the
person who is creating those algorithms
creating those new ways of working and
not a victim of it and you know it's a
it's a scary thing to think that you
know a computer might be able to do my
job in 10 years but if I'm the one
trying to figure out how to create the
algorithms create the software that can
do that job I can have a long and viable
career it's it's certainly scary but I
think you know there's always been
productivity there's always been
technological change question is can you
become the driver of it rather than the
victim yeah I'm currently in the middle
of reading the book life 3.0 by max
tegmark which is mostly about artificial
intelligence but it does address issues
of technological automation more broadly
and what idea he had and it may have
been him quoting someone else I don't
remember offhand was the idea that the
jobs that are going to persist and
remain through automation are likely to
be the ones that operate in subjective
spaces rather than objective spaces jobs
where for example personality does play
an important role or jobs that are more
related to a subjective advice rather
than objective analyses of data so to
speak that type of thing do you have any
strong feelings one way or the other if
we were to start trying to categorize
now the types of jobs that will and will
not be automated away I think we can
definitely start doing that and I think
that framework that you just laid out is
is very much accurate um so I you know I
have some examples in the book so if you
know in medicine for example if you're a
radiologist who looks at you know x-rays
all day and tries to identify things in
the x-rays that's the kind of thing that
really can be automated and increasingly
is you know an area where software can
be really effective if you're an
emergency room doctor that's never gonna
be automated that's very much a human
touch very requires great flexibility
great kind of quick intelligence to see
what's wrong with somebody you know it's
that's not going to be automated in our
lifetimes in in the law and legal
business right if you're reviewing
contracts all day if you're a lawyer
just reviewing contracts for you know
possible problems that's the kind of
thing the software is getting better and
better at if you're a courtroom lawyer
if you're a trial lawyer well as long as
we have the legal system we do now
that's something that that's still gonna
be viable so I think you know there's
basically two choices one was what I was
saying a moment ago about being the
driver of technological change in your
industry being the radiologist who helps
make that software work the other
approach is is choose one of those jobs
choose one of those paths that's going
to be very hard for computers to catch
up to humans is this something that
should already be figuring into the
majors that students in college are
selecting to me it's less about what
your major is in college it's more about
what you do while you're in college I
think the the key thing I learned over
and over is the importance of
adaptability and the cultivating and
ability to try different things stretch
outside your comfort zone and I truly
come to believe that adaptability it's
not just a trait you're either born with
or not it's something that you can
cultivate in yourself and the way you do
it is by pushing yourself in new
directions and the best time to do that
is when you're either in college grad
school early career jobs where the
stakes are relatively low and if you you
know fall on your face it's not as big a
deal so what that means is whatever your
core major your core subject to you know
is stretch yourself in some areas
completely different from that so if
you're a you know if you're a literature
English kind of words person you know
take a couple of hard computer science
classes try a language that doesn't come
naturally to you if you're more of a
math person a numbers person you know
maybe write for the student paper or you
know go out for a play in college do
something that's pushing yourself in new
ways and keep doing that over and over
you keep doing that in your teens and
20s it'll become a lot easier to do it
in your 40s and 50s when you're in your
career I believe that eventually I don't
know if it's in five years twenty-five
years or fifty or a hundred years but
eventually there's going to have to be
some sort of serious reexamination of
just the relationship of humans to the
concept of working a full-time job
either for hourly wages or salary in
order to be able to achieve a sort of
viable life in the West so to speak we
can talk about it more worldwide but in
the West maybe we can focus our
conversation do you agree that that
re-examination is going to have to take
place
if so when do you think it's going to
have to happen and but maybe most
interestingly are any big corporations
thinking about that at this point in
time so I do think we have to kind of
reopen these questions you know famously
back in the 1930s john maynard keynes
thought that by this time we'd only be
working you know three hour work weeks
or something like that didn't quite go
that direction so i in the last chapter
the book i tried to kind of reflect on
what i had learned about about having a
thriving good career and i did some
laughs and the math is this so if you
start working at age 22 after college if
you're retired 65
if you sleep eight hours a night you do
the math works out to about four million
hours you have to work with over the
course of your kind of prime working
years you know those are your waking
hours and and look that's the hardest
constraint of them all and we all have
trade-offs to engage in between our jobs
our hobbies and and pursuits and our
families and kind of home life and I
don't I'm not trying to be prescriptive
about how to juggle those trade-offs I
you know I titled this book how to win
not how to become a billionaire or how
to become a CEO of a fortune 500 company
because those paths aren't for everybody
and I think there can be a really
rewarding life to be had that that does
treat work differently than that kind of
always on you know we've got to put in
80 hours at the office kind of culture
and I think the important thing is being
deliberate and thoughtful about what you
find rewarding where your ambitions go
and and reacting accordingly you know I
think smart companies are realizing that
you know there can be a role for people
who only do a part-time schedule who are
willing to sacrifice a little income to
you know have a more you know 20 30
hours a week instead of 40 or 50 but but
you know I think the I think as time
goes on I think more companies are going
to realize that they need that ability
to to adapt with people's desires and
kind of work like trade offs are there
specific decisions you've made in your
life that most people wouldn't
necessarily think to because you work in
this space and research this this topic
yeah I think the I think the biggest
thing that I've really kind of
internalized is is an idea that
it's actually from Reid Hoffman who is
the founder of LinkedIn he calls it
tours of duty and that's a concept
that's existed in the military and in
the diplomatic world for a long time but
in the corporate world the idea is after
you spend a certain amount of time doing
a project building something whatever
you were hired to do then you have a
real discussion with your employer and
is there a way to to stretch yourself in
some new direction take on some new
project I'm kind of breaking up your
career into into unit so I I call it the
3-year itch first year in a new job
you're just trying to you know get up to
speed second year you're hitting your
stride you're getting good at that job
then the third year rolls around it's
time to start thinking about what's the
next thing and can I stretch myself in
some new direction it's doing that over
and over that helps on that adaptability
theme we're talking about a minute ago
in my own career I've done that partly
by changing jobs a few times but also by
doing something like this book and for
me you know I've been at the New York
Times for about three years when I kind
of looked around and said okay what how
I going to push myself stretch myself in
a new direction and this book was came
out of that super interesting book we've
been talking with Neil Irwin who is the
author of how to win in a
winner-take-all world the book is about
navigating a successful career in the
modern economy he's also a senior
economic correspondent at the New York
Times Neil thanks so much for talking to
me and congratulations on the book
thanks a lot David